[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
julien aubert bonjour vous merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous députés les
républicains de vaucluse merci d'être
notre invité en ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre au tombeau jean-fabrice bons
jours et des jours noirs groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
dont le dauphiné libéré julien ouvert on
a appris hier la mort d'olivier dassault
votre collègue député les républicains
de l'oise le fils de serge dassault qui
s'est tué dans le crash de son
hélicoptère
quelle a été votre réaction à l'annoncé
de sa mort c'est toujours enfin ça a été
une sentiment de stupéfaction parce
qu'olivier est d'être un garçon
attachant
dynamique apprécié de tous quelqu'un qui
était à la tête à la fois d'une très
belle entreprise et qui en même temps
est également très simple et c'est
évidemment une perte tragique pour le
groupe l'est républicain parce que nous
perdons à la fin une force de travail à
la fois un homme apprécié de tous et
puis aussi quelqu'un qui a une
connaissance intime du milieu de
l'industrie
c'est qui est toujours une force pour un
pour un groupe comme le nôtre une
certaine idée de la france aussi oui une
certaine idée de la france et même si
l'été je dirais c'est parfois un peu
plus libéral que moi qui n'ai pas trop
les énarques
j'ai dit à génération entreprise enfin
je suis à génération entreprise le club
qu'il avait fondée effectivement ils
avaient à coeur l'intérêt l'intérêt
national faisait partie de ces
capitaines d'industrie qui aiment la
france est évidemment c'est toujours
quelque chose qui ne peut que nous
renforcer
on a parlé de la crise sanitaire bien
sûr je les enverrai une accélération de
la vaccination ce week-end on l'a vu à
plusieurs centres ont ouvert beaucoup de
vaccination notamment dans les
départements les plus touchés ce que ça
vous rassure mais goûter façon on ne
battra ce virus qu'une fois que l'on
aura limité claude collective donc on
doit effectivement atteindre une
vaccination massive et pakistanais le
gouvernement fait ce qu'il faut sur
laquelle régime syrien où je me
permettrai pas de 2,2 fin de la
polémique disons bon tout le monde a
constaté qu'on n'était pas dans les
premiers au départ bon que certains pays
font mieux voilà quand on regarde israël
ou la grande bretagne on se dit que nous
ne sommes pas forcément dans la dans le
peloton de tête et donc effectivement je
suis rassuré de ce point de vue là que
le gouvernement ait pris conscience
qu'il fallait passer à la vitesse
supérieure maintenant la question qui se
pose c'est que c'est une course de
vitesse entre les variantes et le vaccin
est on le sait plus on vaccine plus on
voit aussi l'apparition de variants qui
seront irréductibles je dirais à au
vaccin qui ont été déployés donc on peut
s'attendre par exemple à voir arriver à
un
varian israélien peut-être et difficulté
c'est que évidemment si nous nous sommes
en retard ne nous prendront aussi dans
la tête
non seulement le fait de ne pas avoir
été vacciné suffisamment tôt mais en
plus les variants futur qui seront plus
résistants et contre lesquelles on croit
encore moins protégé donc c'est vraiment
une course de vitesse sur la question
des soignants avec la vaccination des
soignants
vous en pensez quoi il faut obliger les
soignants à ce vaccin se faire vacciner
moi je crois que c'est pas admissible de
la part des français de se faire
contaminer par des soignants
alors le vaccin ne protège pas forcément
de la contamination
mais en tout cas oui je pense que c'est
nécessaire indispensable que les
soignants se fassent vacciner
deuxièmement aussi on voit bien que
l'une des questions quand on a beaucoup
de patients qui ont peur d'être vacciné
qu'est ce qu'ils disent à leur médecin
et vous est-ce que vous ayez de vacciner
si le médecin dit non moi vous comprenez
j'ai des doutes
vous n'avez pas comprendre vous avez pas
convaincre la nonagénaire de sauter le
pas maintenant est-ce qu'il fallait
jusqu'à la rendre obligatoire cette
récréation oui bon il faut à mon avis
pour les soignants il faut la rendre
obligatoire
alors je sais que c'est pas quelque
chose qui est agréable en temps mais
aussi on effectivement dans une guerre
contre le virus qu'on a des soldats au
contact eh bien il ya une mission de
service public et je crois que alors
après doit aussi faire le travail à côté
d'eux
d'éclaircissement parce que il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
vous prenez l'astra et des cas on a
d'abord dit qu'il était pas assez
efficaces soient les plus de 65 ans
après on est revenu en arrière
donc on peut se mettre aussi à la place
des gens un peu plus les complications
peut se mettre à la place des gens je
dirais qui tu vois passer des
informations contradictoires
donc il ya aussi un travail de
rationalisation de la parole publique
donc oui il faut la rendre obligatoire
est ce que c'est votre position
personnelle ou est ce que c'est une
position qui est partagée au sein des
républicains est ce qu'au parlement vous
allez déposer un texte donc par
extension sur l'ancien tracé ma position
à titre individuel ce n'est pas à
l'opposition de faire le travail du
gouvernement
rappelons que c'est au gouvernement de
prendre ses responsabilités dans cette
cette affaire se décider si oui ou non
il doit y avoir accès à sion visé par le
gouvernement et président de la
république en l'occurrence qui a pris
une décision très personnelle de ne pas
re confie c'est une décision politique
très forte qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous en tant qu'opposant je crois que la
solution du confinement c'est la pire
qu'on puisse avoir soit la table et ceux
qui étaient admissibles
moi j'étais partisan d'un confinement au
départ parce que je pensais que c'était
une affaire de quelques mois au bout
d'un an se pose la question parce qu'on
a l'impression que on alterne entre
confinement confinement et déconfinement
pas du tout le couvre-feu est quelque
chose qui est tout aussi usant
moralement psychologiquement socialement
économiquement pour la population en
réalité nous sommes sous couvercle
depuis un an
la question que je me pose non pas en
tant que médecin main tant que
responsable politique c'est combien de
temps est-ce que cette situation peut
encore durer
de mon point de vue ça n'est pas
possible aujourd'hui le gouvernement
nous dit vous inquiétez pas en avril on
y verra plus clair moelleux pour le coup
je suis très circonspect quand je vois
les études épidémiologiques j'ai pas du
tout l'impression que ça va s'améliorer
en avril donc partons du principe que ça
peut encore durer un an parce que même
avec une vaccination en fin d'année qui
serait complète sur le territoire
national avec les histoires de variants
personne n'est capable aujourd'hui de
vous dire 2021 c'est la fin du virus
est ce que cette société peut continuer
à vivre encore un an avec ses
restaurants fermés avec des entreprises
qui fonctionnait
demi-régime et quel est le jeu dire l
avenir où la sortie du tunnel qu'on a
nos français donc je comprends bien
toutes les mesures
de santé mais je crois qu'à un moment
donné il faut changer stratégie je
plaide plutôt mois pour qu on dise aux
plus vulnérables auto confiné vous à
titre préventif
sortons des logiques s'ils voulaient
d'encadrement de vérification de ce que
vous ayez votre votre titre c'est chacun
sa responsabilité et toul d'ailleurs
toutes les personnes âgées
je rencontre autour de mort ça fait un
an si vous voulez quelques d'elle-même
elle se protège et puis après vous avez
des gens qui ont un taux de létalité
très faible et aujourd'hui on est en
train de leur enlever la jeunesse donc
leur jeunesse donc cela il faut les
entendre aussi la souffrance des
étudiants de tout de tout les 30 ha les
vingt ans et c'est donc ainsi n'ont pas
classe dont bon nombre 8 pour moi ya pas
de confinement
je pense qu'on devrait dire si à un
moment donné il ya une reprise de
l'épidémie auto confinement c'est à dire
on dit aux gens de vous même et restez
chez vous parce que c'est compliqué et
si on devait faire un confinement
je suis pour un confinement strict de
par exemple un mois et là vous vacciner
massivement mais massivement ça veut
dire avec la logistique militaire
vous arrivez dans la rue et vous dites
aujourd'hui un camion de vaccination
vous taper à la porte
tout le monde ne sera vacciné revient à
la maison ça oui c'est à dire que si à
la fin du mois vous avez vacciner 30 %
des français ou 20% 25% des français
alors oui je dis banco et puis après
c'est même pas de restrictions de
déplacements vous non reprise il est un
peu pris en sandwich entre la drôme et
les bouches du rhône qui sont de départ
en vrai problème
est ce que vous dites est ce que vous
dites il faut limiter les déplacements
dans ces régions est ce qu'il faut
prendre des mesures plus restrictives
toujours des contradictions s'ils
voulaient que j'ai du mal à caen voulez
vous expliquer aux gens qu'il faudrait
mettre des restrictions à l'intérieur du
pays mais par contre que les frontières
de l'union européenne sont ouvertes
il n'y a pas de pourquoi est-ce que moi
j'aurais pas le droit d'aller dans un
département voisin où il ya par exemple
des foyers en foyers épidémiques plus
faibles en revanche je peux aller en
allemagne où le virus souvent en
angleterre pour l'angleterre a lancé un
peu complice est plus compliqué mais ou
l'espagne où il ya des agressions et
depuis des mois d'efforts tiers penser
ça la question
et donc je crois qu'il faut de ce point
de vue là une philosophie unique
on peut pas en fonction je dirait de la
manière dont on conçoit l'espace décrété
que c'est sanitairement ou pas
acceptable un dernier mois là tu es ce
que vous êtes favorables aux pass
sanitaires non non pour l'instant je
suis pas favorable autant sur la
vaccination des soignants jeu je consens
oui mais le pass sanitaire soit si vous
voulez vous n'avez pas tout le monde qui
peut avoir recevoir le vaccin
et dans ce cas là vous créez la double
discrimination c'est à dire que le jeune
vous lui dit tu as 30 ans t'as pas loin
d'être vacciné et en plus il faut faire
attention à bouger parce que parce
maxine alors je prends les vrais
sanitaire s'est pas exactement le
passage final c'est plutôt de wever code
pour aller dans les lieux salle de sport
restaurant théâtre
oui bah non plus non non non je
préférais si vous voulez qu'on fasse des
tests pcr
si vous êtes négative vous pouvez
effectivement aller prendre le train
aller au théâtre etc mais pas sur tout
cas sur les vaccins on va passer à un
autre sujet on va parler des violences
nouvelles violences ce week-end
notamment dans la banlieue lyonnaise à
rillieux-la-pape à bron
gérald darmanin il dit que ce sont des
représailles suite au coup de collier
données par les policiers dans le
démantèlement de trafic de drogue est ce
que vous partagez son analyse le mot et
terribles représailles aux représailles
cécile moore président j'ai eu peur
parce que moi j'ai vu ces violences sont
inacceptables
est ce que je trouve terrible tragique
c'est que les mots en réalité son
démenti tous les jours par l'effet mer
que tous les jours dit cette violence
est inacceptable et tous les jours les
riverains les habitants sont obligés de
l'accepter et parce que ça va dire la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue
je crois que nous avons un vrai problème
de trafic de drogue partout moi je les
ai également vaucluse à carpentras
cavaillon des banques qui font la loi
carpentras avis le 30 mille habitants
vous avez des types qui tient dans la
rue à 15h de l'après midi quand même lui
le 30 mai d'habitants
donc nous avons un vrai sujet de deux
points de trafic de drogue là qu'il soit
près de savoir si nos policiers il faut
les utiliser pour contrôler les gens qui
à 19 heures entre des remparts en ville
parce qu'ils ont violé le couvre-feu ou
si on veut les utiliser plus tôt pour
éradiquer le trafic de drogue et ensuite
est-ce que c'est uniquement une réponse
policière ou est-ce que derrière la
réponse judiciaire et est adapté non
pour moi aujourd'hui le vrai homme
faible vrai corps malade c'est la
justice la police britannique et c'est
la sanction c'est l'application c'est
l'application de la sanction il faut
arrêter de voter des lois en réalité
l'important ce n'est pas le fait de dire
vous vous risquez dix ans de prison ou 7
ans de prison
l'important c'est de savoir s'il ya 99%
si vous êtes attraper par la police
vous allez faire la peine qui est en
cours c'est la probabilité d'application
de la peine qui est importante pas la
force de la peine je préfère à la limite
deux ans de prison mais vous avez 99% de
chances de le faire que dix ans de
prison et vous avez 5 % je caricature un
peu sur les chocs mais vous savez qu'à
une peine sur dix seulement qui est
vraiment appliqué dans sa totalité à
votre place vendredi matin nous avions
dû carvounas le maire d'alfortville
qui clairement ne me disaient les
bracelets électroniques par exemple pour
lui quand on lis entre les lignes ce
n'est pas une peine
ça ne correspond pas à une peine
effective vous en pensez quoi
je sais pas à quel type de défi il pense
mais pour moi la prise par idées mêmes
délinquants que ce coup c'est pour moi
si vous voulez la prison est souvent
attaqué en disant de comprenez ça c'est
l'école du crime
la prison est d'abord faite pour retirer
de la circulation des gens dangereux
c'est pour moi ça sa vocation c'est pas
de permettre aux détenus de se réinsérer
après sa peine c'est mieux s'il peut
effectivement trouver une nouvelle voie
que c'est cramé d'abord enlever de la
circulation des gens dangereux
il ya beaucoup trop de gens dangereux et
la responsabilité de ce gouvernement
c'est d'ailleurs pendant le premier
confinement d'avant ouvert les prisons
n'est d'avoir fait sortir toute une
série de gens qui étaient dangereux et
moi j'aimerais d'ailleurs qu'un jour qui
est une petite étude qui soit faite
entre les milliers de gens qu'on a
laissé sortir et la recrudescence de
violence qu'on connaît maintenant depuis
un an est ce que vient pas non je pose
la question parce que m'en donner tous
ces gens si vous voulez qu'ils avaient
des passifs judiciaire on les a mis en
liberté donc je doute je voulais qu'ils
soient tous revenus chez eux émis les
charentaises et décidé de reprendre une
activité normale
et puis le bracelet électronique est
souvent mis en avant etc
c'est une peine qu'il faut qu'il faut
donner à des gens qui ne sont pas
dangereux je veux dire quand vous avez
un avis politique et qui est condamné
bon ben vous pouvez laisser en liberté
c'est pas lui qui va agresser les gens
dans la rue donc lille peut porter un
bracelet en référence à nicolas sarkozy
ne fait aucune référence à peu un homme
politique existant ou ayant existé très
mais ça devait arriver par exemple on va
en parler pendant quelques instants mais
d'abord un mot sur ce qui se passe à
grenoble notamment l diop et de grenoble
1 aux deux professeurs ont été ciblés
accusé d'islamophobie à des affiches
anonymes les cibles ont été collées à
l'entrée de l'école une enquête a été
ouverte pour injure publique et
dégradations qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette situation je pense que ce leurs
visées
l'université c'est à dire que on voit
bien aujourd'hui que des professeurs du
port après on a le droit
c'est le pluralisme des opinions qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec le point de vue
dominant sont mis à la vindicte menacé
physiquement et donc c'est fait pour les
intimider les faire taire c'est bien ce
que j'ai critiqué sur les dérives
idéologiques de l'université c'est pour
cette raison que j'ai proposé une
mission d'information avec damien abad
c'est pour cette raison que nous étions
très agacé de voir que personne ne va
absolument lever le couvercle et il a
fallu la pousser par an trois mois parce
que je rappelle que les deux missions
d'information
ces noces et novembre mais c'est le jour
où monsieur ferrand a refusé en disant
on n'a pas de moyens ou c'est pas notre
priorité
comme un vide à des sorties sur le cnrs
j'ai deux roues est quand même
incroyable que le cnrs dont les fonds
cher 10 coûteux et nous on accepte de
faire la l'étude de madame le ministre
enfin on y croit pas trop parce que ça
n'existe pas bon si elle veut écouter
avec toutes les précautions on va quand
même tenté de regarder c'est sûr vous ne
partez pas avec la volonté farouche de
lutter contre le fléau
et là encore rien donné pour mai et
encore on fait de la danse de ballerines
alors qu'il faudrait tirer sur ceux sur
ce sujet
avec avec force parce que c'est un fléau
il est en train est endémique
il ya effectivement tous les sujets
qu'on peut avoir de pauvreté etc
ce n'est pas le problème mais si pour
moi c'est un jédir et c'est une
idéologie fascisante parce qu'elle
essentialise les individus c'est très
dangereux une idéologie qui s'attaque à
vous non pas parce que vous pensez
quelque chose mais parce que vous pouvez
être blanc parce qu on peut être homme
parce que vous pouvez être catholique
c'est de ce point de vue là on doit
ouvrir les yeux sur ce qui se passe je
parle du phénomène global de la can
cette culture et de l'islam aux
gauchistes qui lui est associée elle a
été lâchée
madame vidal mais on sait pas trop parce
qu'en fait elle a été lâchée par
emmanuel macron play les revenus dans le
jdd donc c'est assez compliqué
c'est le point de vue en même temps
quand vous êtes face à la bête vous
pouvez pas faire née en même temps tous
les gens qui donnent des leçons
antifascisme depuis 30 ans moi je les
vois pas là aujourd'hui mais quand vous
êtes face à un tel adversaire vous
pouvez pas dire on va faire un peu mais
pas trop non
il faut il faut savoir de quel côté on
est moi je vis il faut éradiquer ces
courants de pensée déconstructionniste
qui s'attaque à l'identité nationale qui
s'attaque aux gens pour ce qu'ils sont
qui sont essentialisant qui sont
fascisant il faut les prendre comme tel
et il faut tout faire en sorte pour
qu'il ne prospère plus dans les
universités sinon ce que nous avons à
grenoble et bien se propagera voilà même
si sur un jour public la notion
d'islamophobie pour moi n'est pas une
injure
on a le droit d'avoir peur d'une
religion je n'aime pas trop ce terme en
tout cas qualifié d' un jour on va
parler des propos de françois hollande
dès hier matin dans le parisien il a
défendu le parquet national financier
qui a été créé sous sa présidence et dit
ne pas comprendre que le garde des
sceaux est qu emmanuel macron n'ai pas
réagi après les critiques venues de
votre camp sur l'indépendance du parquet
national financé suite à la condamnation
de nicolas sarkozy qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé des propos de françois
hollande hier oki régler ses comptes
avec la manière malgré nicolas sarkozy
deux anciens présidents de la république
entre lesquels il a tenté d'exister
et pour lesquels il n'a pas une grande
affection après c'est pas étonnant que
françois hollande qui a créé le pn et
viennent au secours de sa de son fils
spirituel
maintenant j'ai j'ai manqué de
m'étouffer
quand il est venu la main sur le coeur
expliqué que tout cela fonctionne et en
toute impartialité
je rappelle quand même que je rappelle
quand même que la presse s'est fait
l'écho de madame houlette qui expliquait
qu'elle avait des pressions de madame
archambault le procureur général de
monsieur amar qui est l'adjoint de
madame ou led qui enquêtait sur elle en
pensant que c'était une tourbe d'un
homme politique
on dit toujours il n'ya pas
d'indépendance en justice financière en
justice alors d'abord à parquet n'est
pas indépendant par définition est
heureusement et deuxièmement parce
qu'ils appliquent une politique pénale
et deuxièmement il ya en justice qu'on
appelle la théorie des apparences vous
pouvez être totalement impartial et
juste et indépendant si vous donner
l'apparence de ne pas l'être alors dans
ce cas là on vous retire la faire parce
que tout s'écroule et dans le cas
d'espèce
comment voulez vous qu'un justiciable
comme nicolas sarkozy puisse croire à
l'indépendance du pnr
quand il a été créé par son adversaire
politique que la preuve le principal
fait de gloire du pdf et d'avoir
assassiné ou contribué à l'assassinât
d'un autre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et que dans la presse
témoigne le fait que les types en
réalité ce suspect que les uns les
autres d'être instrumentalisé
politiquement parce qu'au moment donné
on gère on veut tous faire des efforts
mais il faudrait aussi que le pnf to z
il faut revoir le fonctionnement voire
l'existence du pétrole dissoudre coûté
le pnf a été créé pour imaginer pour
enquêter sur des affaires judiciaires
complexe moi j'avais compris que
c'étaient les paradis fiscaux les
comptes en suisse à la fin vous
retrouvez avec les costumes de monsieur
fillon et les écoutes téléphoniques de
quelqu'un avec son avocat dans le cadre
d'une enquête plus globale donc on est
très éloigné du sujet on va continuer à
parler de nicolas sarkozy pour terminer
on va parler politique puisque
il dit qu'il dira qu'il soutiendra en
2022 mais il ne dit pas qui laisse
entrevoir un doute sur le fait que ça
pourrait être emmanuel macron est ce que
vous vous comprendriez si tel était le
cas
non mais vous n'excluez pas à bojan
serais je suis pas dedans mais je ne
sache pas qui soutenir puisque moi-même
aux républicains qui suit tous les jours
et publiées je ne sais pas qui je vais
se dire puisque nous ne savons pas
quelle sera notre mode de sélection et
quel sera notre candidat donc ses traits
assez compliqué de faire un travail de
projection
après à la question si demain nicolas
sarkozy soutenait manuel macro est ce
que je le comprendrais non parce que
j'appartiens à une famille politique et
qui est dans l'opposition
par rapport à la politique d' emmanuel
macron parce que je pense qu'il ya tout
un pan de la politique d' emmanuel
macron notamment sur les sujets
sociétaux swaps et m'assure sur
l'environnement qui sont en réalité du
gauchisme mal mal digérée et donc non je
n'ai pas hésité l'été le cas un peu de
politique fiction est ce que pour vous
ça crée une rupture entre les
républicains et nicolas sarkozy ça
créerait une fracture au sein dlr sacré
peut-être qu'il pense que ça peut être
créé ça peut te sacré peut-être une
clarification entre ceux qui sont aux
républicains estiment en réalité que
nous sommes des frères siamois avaient
l'un et huit en marche et ceux qui
pensent que la droite ce n'est pas
forcément défendre le démantèlement de
l'industrie nationale
liv et j'ai à 14 semaines et puis toute
une série de mesures environnementales
qui vient des trophées l'industrie mais
font voile est nécessaire cette
clarification
bonjour je crois que on a le droit en
démocratie d'avoir des points de vue
différents
il faut il faut juste faire attention de
ne pas prendre les lecteurs et les
citoyens pour un imbécile et lui faire
prendre des vessies pour des lanternes
donc si j'ai dirhams en déduire une
grande clarification et que les quelques
uns chez nous qui en fait sont un peu
ambigu décidé de se clarifier
écoutez je pense que tout le monde
gagnerait mais te fait monsieur robert
la droite est très absente aujourd'hui
elle a du mal à se faire entendre
qu'est-ce qu'elle a loupé et à quel
moment
je crois que la droite premièrement n'a
pas fait un travail de réflexion sur les
raisons de ces échecs
elle a toujours finalement elle vit
toujours sur cette idée que le pays est
à droite qui de toute façon le balancier
va revenir alors c'est en train de
s'étioler parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
travail de réflexion qui est fait par
par christian jacob par le new par le
parti qui essaye justement de revenir
sur le champ des idées c'est très bien
j'ai longtemps plaidé pour ceux ci en
interne et deuxièmement je crois que
c'est aussi un affaiblissement c'est à
dire que la droite c'est les
républicains mais les républicains
les parties sont de plus en plus faible
parce qu'à cette désaffection public
et puis un travail de renouvellement
aussi les générations et parce qu'avec
chaque génération s'est pas seulement
une question d'âge vous savez il ya des
gia des jeunes coqs et il ya des jeunes
de choses mais en même temps je crois si
vous voulez que la société évolue
rapidement et que en en rafraîchissant
je dirais nos cadres ou non n'est plus
en contact avec le pouls de la société
est une des raisons pour lesquelles en
marche ou leur assemblée nationale a
aussi bien fonctionné c'est parce que ce
sont des jeunes partis qui ont propulsé
des jeunes de 20 à 25 30 ans forcément
mes tournois à la place des lycéens
c'est plus facile de s'identifier
peut-être un jour donne bardella que
quelqu'un qui al'âge de son père donc
c'est un problème d'identification et
nous avons aussi un sujet de candidats
parce que nous avons des divergences
internes idéologique et qu'à un moment
donné il faudra les régler parce que
nous sommes un grand parti de droite et
du centre et que nous avons une partie
de notre électorat qui penche vers la
droite et un autre qui plongea le centre
vous savez manière vous pouvez les
régler la primaire ça sera pas la seule
solution pour moi je crois que c'est aux
adhérents les républicains de trancher
massivement et prioritairement et je
milite évidemment pour une droite qui
s'assume et qui retrouve l'intérêt
national
parce que je pense que c'est la campagne
prochaine présidentielle
or aucun accord la nation la
souveraineté l'identité et l'écologie et
vous reviendrez nous en parler d'ici là
merci beaucoup merci je n'ai revers
d'avoir été notre invité regarde la une
du dauphiné libéré
fabrice les toffes des héroïnes et ben
oui nous sommes
je vous rappelle le 8 mars journée des
droits des femmes et c'est à la une du
dauphiné libéré merci merci julien
aubert en face suite au club d'états et
à la mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
[Musique]